en el día del jubileo de platino la
reina isabel segunda garantiza el futuro
de la monarquía británica y también una
transición segura y estable para cuando
ella ya no esté en un mensaje a la
nación la monarca puso fin a años de
especulaciones porque es su más sincero
deseo de que camila duquesa de
cornualles se convierta en reina
consorte una vez que el príncipe carlos
se convierta en rey la figura de camila
duquesa de cornualles ha sido polémica
entre el público británico en los
últimos años ya que a ella se le culpa
del fracaso del matrimonio entre el
príncipe carlos y la princesa diana y
durante muchos años se dijo que la
duquesa sería princesa consorte así
celebran y comienzan los festejos de los
70 años de la reina isabel al frente del
trono británico- en el palacio de
buckingham donde nos encontramos en el
mes de junio
a un fin de semana festivo para celebrar
este icónico evento este histórico
evento ya que la monarca es la más
longeva y también la que más tiempo ha
estado al frente de la corona británica